you know as many times as we say it out
loud it's pretty unbelievable that eric
swalwell a member of the house
intel committee had sex with a chinese
spy called fang fang
it's remarkable it's also remarkable
that patrick donahoe
is a major general in the u.s army
now he's a general but he doesn't seem
as interested in keeping the country
safe
as he does in promoting a very specific
political point of view so he spends
most of his time apparently online
harassing political opponents of the
biden administration
last week general donahoe was lecturing
a student at hillsdale college
on the merits of mandatory vaccines hey
hillsdale come get your boy wrote
general donahoe that guy's really a
general
that's when another user asked this
quote hey general how many wars have you
won
now rather than asking that question
honestly of course the answer is
zero patrick donahoe responded this way
quote
don't be a shill for putin so here you
have a major general in the u.s
army accusing apparently an american
citizen of being a quote
chill for putin because that person
criticized
joe biden are you comfortable with that
with a highly politicized u.s military
military that
acts basically as the armed enforcers
of the bide administration we shouldn't
be comfortable with it ned ryan is
founder and ceo of american majority he
joins us tonight
ned i just i can't help thinking you
know you think of all the guys
who join the u.s military because they
love america and they want to defend the
country and we're endlessly grateful for
their real sacrifice and they are it's
not just
it's a cliche but it's true they do
sacrifice in a big way and then they
have leaders like this who spend their
days on twitter calling people
putin shills because they disagree with
biden like how
why is this guy still commanding anyone
why isn't he resigned seriously
well it's because i think the left has
has yet again been
successful in another long march through
yet another institution which is the
senior leadership of our military
uh which i don't think should be that
surprising tucker i mean a lot of these
senior officers have gotten advanced
degrees from
indoctrination centers of higher
learning like harvard or columbia
and a lot of them got their stars i
think if we were to look back in the
obama administration where they got
advancement not necessarily through
merit of
how good are you at tactics how good you
are killing and destroying
but how good are you parroting the
left's talking points and even more so
it appears this general donahoe thinks
that he'll win praise and advancement by
attacking conservatives and populists
uh that's where it's gotten to and and
you're right now we've gotten to this
point where we have a major general in
in in the military uh who looks at
attacking a private citizen's right to
speech which includes a right to dissent
as though it's the right thing to do
instead of actually defending their
constitutional rights
to be able to have freedom of speech and
freedom of descent i think tucker
conservatives need to
have an adjustment in their thinking and
start to look at the world in a
different filter
in which the doj and the fbi and quite
frankly the military which are supposed
to defend the rule of law
and protect americans basic rights are
no longer doing that are basically
acting as a praetorian guard for the
ruling class the administrative state
which is i think a very dangerous place
for us
not only domestically tucker but also on
the international level as well because
a woke military
against the chinese is not a good thing
i don't understand why republicans in
the congress
why mitch mcconnell or adam kinzinger or
liz cheney who say they support her why
do they sign off in the military budget
why don't they say
i i want to fund the military i want to
defend the country but patrick donahoe
has to leave fort benning and resign you
can't have a politicized military that's
insane why does nobody say that
because i think republicans especially
have lost sight of the fact that they do
have oversight but they've lost the guts
they've lost the courage to do so
in which the chris reyes and the
donahoes of this world who refuse to
have oversight who have
politicized the military and the fbi uh
continue to do these things because they
think they can get away with it and it's
simply a lack of political courage by
many republicans in dc
who would rather posture on tv or send
sharply worded letters
instead of actually doing something by
cutting budgets and having real
consequences
i i feel so sorry for the people who
serve under donahoe he should resign
immediately he's a disgrace
i'm sure you're coming on ned ryan thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else